it's lunch day for the Apple watch today
the company's latest gadget will go on
pre-order and will begin shipping on
April 24th but so far it has been
getting some mixed reviews we've had
back for that you watch joining us now
Bloomberg managing enter Sam grobart so
Sam do I want one or do I need one well
wow you know to read the reviews you
can't really tell can you I mean there's
sort of more hedging going on here than
a Parisian garden it's it's you know
people seem incapable of making the
simple point that right now while the
Apple watch maybe the best SmartWatch
the SmartWatch is not necessarily a
category of product that everybody needs
right now and I don't think apples shown
that they've really broken any new
ground with that do we not need a
SmartWatch sure has no one gotten it
right no certainly nobody's gotten it
right yet and that's you know when you
look at the history of gadgets and tech
products you know we've seen an
evolution of things where you have mp3
players before the ipod and then the
ipod comes along and kind of makes it
something that we all want the same was
true for the iphone with smartphone but
with the Apple watch that it's a little
reminiscent right now of the ipad it's
which turned out to be successful but
was a little murky at first is this a
watch or is this luxury this jewelry I
mean Angela errands coming from burberry
isn't charged he said she doesn't want
lines this is to make it I guess you
know I have a bit more precise right
it'sit's Algeria so you can pre-order
it's definitely new territory for Apple
and you know you refer to the sort of
new sales strategy in which you can
pre-order online and they're not gonna
have big lines out of the store and I
think part of that's because there's
much more complexity involved with
selling this product than any other
Apple product prior you have 54
different varieties of watch that you
can buy right now as opposed to three
different you know kinds of smartphone
in two colors you know you sat down with
Tim Cook I think three years ago to talk
about his plans for Apple what does this
watch say because they've been
extraordinarily successful with all of
their products and yet we still sit
around and say well he hasn't made a new
thing yet is this his new thing this is
his new thing right this is as you read
on all the reviews I think they all use
the same language language this is the
first product developed you know outside
of the influence of Steve Jobs what does
it say then about Tim Cook's cooks
tenure what it says I think to get to
your earlier point Francine about luxury
is that Apple
fendant Lee wants to sit at the high end
of the market and there was some concern
a couple of years ago that they might
have to move to the lower end when they
developed the iphone 5 seed and people
said oh it's not even cheap enough
you're gonna get your lunch eaten by
less expensive Chinese and Indian
manufacturers an apple said no we're not
and actually that was true they
continued to make a lot of money whereas
a company like Samsung for example
definitely has felt that pressure from
lower price manufacturers okay how much
do you look at wearables because this
you know when you speak to a lot of
people that try and make smart watches
are saying well I'm gonna hold back
let's push Apple out see if that works
and then I'll start making mine and
actually producing and refining mine so
it is this the point where we understand
whether it watches in general work yeah
I think we've tested with a number of
different types of devices we've said
many many of my colleagues and many my
friends where you know fitness trackers
I myself have you used one in the past
the watch though he's a little bit
different I think of watch as being a
piece of jewelry and if we can really
convert and Apple can convince people
that this is something that it's not
just jewelry but also going to add value
to your life and help you connect in a
better way then that's fine but i think
there's there's also a huge amount of
value in being able to disconnect at
this point we're all carrying so many
devices where we're also so
interconnected and on if you can step
away i think that's also quite a luxury
good Sam real quick too does the Apple
has the watch have to be divorced from
the iphone in order to work well the
watch really only works to its fullest
capability if it is paired with the
phones so you're already going to be
carrying one device with you to get the
most out of the second one yeah which
for many people you know just
anecdotally a lot of people are saying I
already have my phone I don't know what
you know why should i also have an added
thing which may add another screen to
distract me to your point I'm not
already disconnect all right Sam grobart
doesn't sound like you're going to get
one